thousands across Bangladesh have lost
their homes due to heavy flooding and
landslides over seven million people
have been affected in hundred and sixty
three thousand hectares of cropland
damaged in 28 distich according to
Bangladesh Red Crescent Society families
have been struggling with the impact of
the floods the worst in two years many
are now facing the elements without any
kind of protection Shilpa Begum mother
of six children is finding it hard to
cope with the situation it's hard to
cook and feed the children a full square
meal when there's so much water still
around their father can't find work when
there's a flood we somehow managed to
survive on dry rice pops many
communities are finding it difficult to
access food and little aid has arrived
so far if we got some financial help
then we could rebuild our home somehow
we could then manage to live a normal
life that's all we want
over 40,000 children are being kept out
of schools which have either been too
damaged to access or are being used as
makeshift shelters there is water
everywhere in my home and at school I
can't study at home and now we are
lagging behind in study the majority of
Bangladeshi lives in rural areas most of
whom rely on agriculture for their
livelihood and it's these communities
that have been hit the hardest
according to environment experts
Bangladesh is becoming increasingly more
vulnerable to climate change especially
those living in river islands and
coastal belts severe flooding has left
many Bangladesh is at risk of disease
and hunger crops have been washed away
livestock killed and fisheries ruined
although water is receding in some
places for the fact that communities
have lost their means to make a living
sandwich Audrey al-jazeera Paris poor
Bangladesh